there are other teams in the nfl and
there is other news that has been
popping up in recent days even though we
focused on the conference championship
games in the super bowl to come let's
start this hour with the latest that
came out over the weekend on tom brady
he spoke with jim gray of westwood one
for pregame for the conference
championship coverage from westwood one
and he said i'm open-minded about this
looming free agency process at the same
time i love playing football i want to
continue to play and do a great job so
i'm looking forward to what's ahead
whatever the future may bring i'll
embrace it with open arms in the
meantime i'm gonna watch these two games
today as a fan and enjoy them from my
couch that was brady to jim gray of
westwood one so look i mean here's the
bottom line
his contract is expiring there's nothing
the patriots can do to keep him other
than convince him to sign a new contract
they can't use a writer foos refusal
franchise tag transition tag none of
that he's gone if he wants to be gone
it's up to him what he wants to do chris
and you know there's been some
speculation about other teams he could
play for but i this is going to be one
of the big stories of the offseason
obviously it reminds me of peyton
manning back in 2012 where will tom
brady go the only difference is with
peyton manning eight years ago there was
never a thought he was going to go back
to the cults right the colts were taking
andrew luck in the draft right there's
still that that possibility of returning
to the patriots it is keeping this from
becoming a bigger deal once that door
closes on the patriots i think that's
when this one explodes yeah i agreed uh
i mean there's so many fascinating
things here i think the first thing is
you know what you learn from these
comments and just from the things brady
says is he it seems like he's willing to
go right he's willing to leave town if
he has to there's no doubt about that i
think that's the surprise number one to
me now when josh mcdaniels didn't get a
head coaching job with one of the five
vacancies i thought oh
that probably bodes well for us all
seeing tom brady back in new england one
more year now the other thing i think we
got to take into into account here
is you know the money situation too you
know i don't know what tom brady's
looking for but if tom brady's looking
to make like a 30 35 million a year or
you know two year contract for 70
million something like that i i don't
think that happens in new england i mean
just my experience with bill belichick
is if he thinks you're worth four cents
he's not giving you five cents he just
won't do it you know and that's another
thing i think we're they're not going to
bring brady back unless it's something
respectable that they feel like they can
build the team around him with at this
point in their career i don't think
they're gonna go one more year and put
themselves deeper into salary cap hell
for brady at 43 years old either i think
belichick and even he could sell that to
craft who we know loves brady too so a
lot of different interesting angles in
this one
and there's been reports that no
hometown discount this time around that
he wants something closer in line with
market value and look there's market
value and then there's his value what is
he really worth at this point and in a
weird sort of a way the struggles of the
patriots offense in 2019 chris makes tom
brady less marketable because it raises
questions about whether or not he still
has it definitely is father time
breathing down his neck and in a
roundabout way it may make it cheaper
and more feasible for the patriots to
keep because here's what will happen
even though we're weeks away from the
start of free agency teams are starting
to make their plans and there will be
conversations that officially never
happened that definitely do happen
behind the scenes between team
representatives and tom brady's agent
don yee about hypothetically what would
be available hypothetically to a
hypothetical 42 soon-to-be 43-year-old
quarterback who hypothetically may be
willing to join a new team
hypothetically that's how it happens so
you gauge the market that way you know
that this team will pay x another team
will pay x plus 3 million a year another
team will pay this so then they'll know
before they tell the patriots no thank
you they'll know what else is out there
that's how it always works and that's
something that may already be happening
it's never going to be announced because
it's tampering yeah it happens all the
time everybody does it but you know the
ultimate decision that will be revealed
at some point before the middle of march
it may be far closer to being made than
people realize because i think already
teams if they're smart if they're
interested in tom brady they're going to
be making it known somehow some way what
they are willing to put on the table to
get brady on their team yeah no i i
think you're right you know and i would
have a hard time you know not believing
that there will be one team out there
that's gonna be
enamored with tom brady and what he
could maybe do for their franchise and
you know
uh
just just oh okay he could still play
hey listen tom brady can still win
football games and do that we know that
you know tom brady like the top 10
quarterback in football and all that
that's over that's done
but you put the right team around him
all right and you know he does know how
to play the game he still has a good arm
and he gives your team belief i think
those are the things that you know
somebody will get enamored with with
brady now who that team is i don't know
uh whether that's the la chargers or
somebody like that i mean that's the
teams i continue to look at it makes
sense to me there for them trying to
make a mark in la too
but yeah you're right these
conversations are going to be start to
be had right around now the teams that
are not in the playoffs and have just
started their off-season work and
getting the head coach involved and all
of that stuff
that's all going to go down over here in
the next five to six weeks
yeah and uh it again remains to be seen
where he goes but i think the one factor
that we need to keep in mind here
because there's been speculation about
the raiders soon to be las vegas because
he was at the ufc fight on saturday
night he was talking to mark davis so
people started saying oh he's going to
the raiders look i don't know how tom
brady and john gruden would interact but
i think it would make for a great
reality show
the the factor in this that we need to
keep in mind is mrs brady we've talked
about this already where does she want
to live i i think we we are deep into
the territory where each additional year
that tommy plays is the product of a
negotiation like any other family right
that's what makes them the one thing
that makes them kind of like the rest of
us if there's anything yeah just one
little thing there's got to be some give
and take between the husband and the
wife on big decisions so where does the
wife want to live
maybe not boston
las vegas i don't know i mean we were
talking a couple of weeks ago about how
the colts could use tom brady i don't
think mrs brady wants no way
indianapolis do you respect indianapolis
yeah so that's going to be a factor in
this as well chris yeah i agreed you
know yeah the listen gisele tom brady i
mean tom's a big city guy and he grew up
right outside of san francisco and then
went to boston
gisele you know yeah she's a supermodel
she's of course used to being around the
scene so i mean to me it's like is it
new york is it boston is it miami is it
la i mean it's really about as simple as
that it's it's one of those i just don't
think that you know giselle and tom
brady are going to move to middle
america or the south and that's no
disrespect to those places i've lived
there i got family there all of that i'm
not i'm just i'm just saying it just
doesn't add up to me between what we've
seen at tom brady and gisele who are you
know they're used to being a they're
going to like that's you know the met
gala in new york city they're just
they're in a different world of
superstar than most of football players
and and of course she's like the number
one you know supermodel in the world so
yeah they're not just going to go
anywhere
and and it's going to be a place that is
on one of the coasts and south and
whether it's miami whether it's la i i
feel like it's going to be one of those
right me too
the standpoint of making it all balanced
yes within that family structure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports